senator bill haggerty who plans to vote
no on this bill joins me now senator
haggerty great to have you in studio so
there's a rush rush rush rush on this
why
i can't tell you why laura because we
have pressing problems right here at
home that we're not addressing you
talked about it earlier in this segment
you've got people in memphis that can't
find formula for their children people
in knoxville that can't gas their tank
up because it's too expensive in my home
state of tennessee i'm from a flyover
state as they call it here in washington
we have real problems here and it
precipitates from the biden
administration the policies they've
taken basically war on america
collapsing our southern border standing
by as china wages war on our youth
killing more people with fentanyl than
any other thing from the ages of 18 to
45 in america that's the number one
killer china's fingerprint is on this
and we're standing by and letting it
happen yet we're rushing to take care of
problems overseas this this total that
we're going to be spending in ukraine it
looks like i mean you kind of have to
compare it to what we spend in
afghanistan so we don't declare war
but we declare war on the american
people's future by spending money that
we don't have
as people are scrounging for baby form
the baby formula story i just it this is
like one of the worst things
was commentaries on the state of america
today certainly it is and i think it
just reflects that the total out of
touch nature of this entire biden
administration as you say they'd rather
wage war on americans criticize
americans and ignore our plight here in
america yet rush to a cause that perhaps
joe biden gets better rating points on
i'm not certain but it certainly isn't
as pressing as what's happening right
here in america yeah congressman massey
made the comment that it's about it's
about the 54 billion
would be suspiciously close when you add
it all up to the annual amount we spent
in afghanistan and it's almost like i
guess he's hitting at the defense
contractors i mean look they're in
business they want to make money i get
it but
that's a big chunk of chunk of money
that is not going to be allocated to a
lot of military interests if they don't
get that money
well that money certainly has a place a
better place and a higher use in my view
to be dealt with issues right here at
home again borrowing money that we don't
have
depending on areas of the world where
there may be a crisis i don't think
america has anything against ukraine we
don't want to see them fail but we have
problems right here at home that we need
should americans die to save finland and
sweden
that's going to be an interesting
question that comes up soon but the
difference with with with finland and
sweden is members of nato they're not
members of nato but if they join they
might actually add to the capacity of
nato what nato has done in the past is
bringing people on that are just
liabilities for us
so when you were
when you were watching the reader we did
on the chinese
buying up farmland in the united states
they bought smith you know smithfield
foods which is 180 150 000 acres of land
and agricultural products which was
eye-raising to me at the time it was
years ago but now more farmland some of
it from marijuana
isn't it time for congress to get
involved here it seems like an invasion
from china at every point laura and
washington is willing to look the other
way every time when it comes to china
yet we're ready to jump on board with
with other problems that uh you know i
think are much more problematic you and
i go over there and buy some land over
in china
that's not possible yeah let's see if we
can
let's see if we can buy a hundred
thousand acres in china that will
absolutely be impossible to do well can
we ask you to follow up on this on the
senate side and see what the heck is
going on because i think americans are
shocked to hear that that was new news
when i saw the report tonight i saw
senator lankford
office involved in this so i'll reach
out to him tomorrow fantastic senator
great to see you good to be with you
laura good to be here hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else